we're talking about cyber security today
and how safe people's passwords are what
is one of your online passwords
currently it is my dog's name in the
year I graduated from high school oh
what kind of dog do you have I have a
chaha Pon and what's his name Jameson
Jameson and where did you go to school
um I went to school back in Greensburg
Pennsylvania what school uh hfield Area
Senior High School oh when did you
graduate in 2009 oh great it's like my
cat's name and then just like a random
number okay is had this cat for a while
yeah she's my childhood pet a and what's
her name her name is Jolie Jolie mhm so
like a password of yours would be Jolie
and then a number yeah like number one
uh like my birthday oh when is your
birthday uh June 12th oh nice what year
were you born uh 95 oh great so Jolie 6
12 95 got it so you mean to give my
password right now no I cannot do that
but we all want to know what it is is so
we can tell you if it's strong or not oh
my goodness
um um let me think okay one is Tel Aviv
yeah
468 and then Israel it's it's only three
but it's you know it's uh for me it's
strong enough Ireland 1 2 3 4
JMA 1 2 3 spell g e m m a well most of
them are are Italian oh beautiful yeah
so like like what's a good Italian
password uh my grandma's name what's
your grandma's name uh Maria Maria so
Maria is your
password oh yeah now you know my
password oh yeah
yeah it's always fun like no matter how
many times I see it you still just look
at it and go
so hopefully that's sort of relaxing
everyone that and the fact that many of
you have got beer which is making me
really jealous right now so I'm going to
try and do this and then join you so I
got to talk about uh something something
cyber and look the something something
was just that I got a lot of ideas and a
lot of things that I think are really
interesting and I thought I'll just I'll
just put them all in a talk and I'll
I'll show you and it'll be a bit of fun
and we'll see a bunch of different stuff
and you know it's a funny thing because
there is just so much going on at the
moment and I see so many interesting
cyber things and I'm I'm honestly never
quite sure when they're even real or not
it's getting that weird and I'm going to
show you some of these today and I I
think you'll uh I think you'll enjoy it
and I hope you'll learn a few things as
well now one of the things that I often
like to start off with when I'm doing
these these talks is to just try and get
a little bit of perspective around
hackers cuz we're going to talk a lot
about hackers right and people hear
about hackers and they have these kind
of images us in their mind like what a
what a hackers what a hackers
do so I thought I better go out get a
bit of material and try and illustrate
exactly what a hacker is so I found some
good info and you'll uh you'll notice
some themes here what do we know about
hackers hoodies very good what
else mat Matrix uh lot of green I don't
know if you knew this but hackers very
very into the
green apparently they like binary too
which I guess is a good thing if they
want to do anything with computers
that's kind of useful and the
interesting thing is is that we see this
imagery over and over again as a
representation of hackers and a lot of
it is because it kind of makes them
scarier right and think about how it
appears in like the Press if we can make
hackers scary we're going to make the
story scary and we know this what the
media does right like they go how scary
can we make this thing because people
will read
it so he you see imagery like this with
hackers now we can learn many things
from here so for example this is how
viruses
spread just like a bucket and they tip
them out they go up the rack and you
know how there's the holes in the top
that's where they get
in the lesson out of this is make sure
you cover the top of your server ax with
something you probably won't get any
viruses after that I'll tell you you may
also have no computers but that's
another
issue so we have this interesting
representation of uh of
scariness and we see scariness over and
over again and we see the themes that
we've just discussed over and over again
and I recently saw a product pop up
that's called Kujo does anyone got a
Cojo no good so Cojo is a little device
you get and you put it in your home no
more hackers it's like magic right and
this is the way they sold
it but the thing is you got to convince
people that they need to worry about
hackers so how are we going to do that
well we make scary videos like this you
may not know it but you've probably
already been hacked thousands of hacking
attacks occur each day now how do we
know he's
hacking hoodie green very good the music
sounds scary like something bad is
happening we know that much but I was
watching this video a little while ago
and this is sort of part of a bigger
video but I'm looking at the screen and
particularly earlier on there's a little
part of the screen that looks like
this and you look at it and you
go looks like a lot like a browser dress
part doesn't it you know it's like the
guy is in the browser and and and that
to to me sort of seemed weird because
this is not what I normally know of
hackers and I thought okay well I got to
go and figure out how is you doing this
and I worked it out I'm going to show
you because this is enormously useful
for you to impress your friends and
family now here's what you do you go to
a website called hackertyper.net
remember this and then while you're
there you just mash the
keyboard now how do we now
attacking green very good all right but
there's there's another trick to this as
well because what you do is it's like
you're mashing the keyboard you got and
I'm going to break into the Pentagon or
something like that Mash Mash mash and
you go let me just see if I can get in
ah damn it no I can't get
in and then you you kind of hack just a
little bit more and you go I've try it
again ah man no all right now hang on I
know how to do it hack hack hack hack
hack yes we're in
amazing
now the thank
you the amazing thing about this is that
this is exactly the code that appeared
in that video like I zoomed and enhanced
and went all CSI on it and you can see
exactly the same code blocks in the
video video as just here and it's a true
thing so this is the way they are try
and tell you that you've got security
issues now I thought we'd uh we'd move
on to a topic on everyone's Minds lately
and I'll I'll just get straight into it
uh now firstly is it just me or does he
look remarkably like a stoned
beaver I don't
know the nice thing is I can go most
places in the world and do this and
everyone thinks it's awesome uh now as
much as we'd like to sit here and sort
of take the piss out of trumple night
there is relevancy to this did you see
that recently he did something
stupid no no there's there's a reason
this was a news headline uh and it's a
serious news headline so what they're
saying is that uh his website could have
been open to these sorts of attacks and
here's the interesting thing we are
going somewhere with this bear with me
he had code on his website like
this now what do you reckon could happen
with JavaScript like
that how much do you trust iore
Escobar because you're loading things
off his GitHub
repository and that the premise that the
Press put forward is that if iar iore
was to put some malicious code on there
it's JavaScript and you can do just
about anything if you can run JavaScript
in someone else's
browser and and this was interesting I
thought okay well we we should sort of
we should demonstrate what you could do
and then we'll demonstrate a defense
that a lot of people don't know about so
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
go over to a website which embeds code
from an external resource embeds it from
cloud flare and then we're going to
start modifying a few things so first of
all let's go to the website and I I
picked a really good one I picked this
one now this is uh trumpdonald.org
and it has this beautiful little thing
where you move the trumpet around you
watch his eyes right and then when you
get to just the right
[Music]
spot and you can just keep going like
around and around and
around as much as you
want now look again we could sit here
all night and do this and it would be
fun but I'm going somewhere with this
let's jump into the source code and if
we do a search for cloud flare you see
how it's embeded resources off
cloudflare all right so they're using
Cloud flare CDN so cloudflare has a
public CDN where they have a whole bunch
of JavaScript libraries CSS fonts all
sorts of things and you can use cloud
flar CDN to embed content in your
site now people do this because when
they do that cloud Flair's got 115 Edge
nodes around the world so no matter
where your customers are they get
something from very very close to them
which is good news so they're going to
get something uh without much latency
the other good thing about it is that
when you load all this stuff off Cloud
flare you don't pay for it it's just off
their public CDN so if you're paying
outbound bandwidth like you do with
something like aure you save that cost
and the other cool thing is that if
someone has already been to a website
that embeds that same Library it's going
to be CED it's going to be fast so there
are lots of good reasons to load content
off public
cdns but people then say okay well we've
got the problem like Trump had with his
website which is what if someone
maliciously modifies that code so what
if someone changes it and does something
to any site that embeds it because again
once you put Javascript on a website you
can kind of do just about anything with
it so I'm going to do a demo here and
I'm going to open up uh Fiddler and
Fiddler has this really neat little
feature called Fiddler script I don't
know how many of you have used this a
lot of people use fidler but not seen
fidler
script and what what's going to happen
now is we've got Fiddler open so our
traffic gets proxied through Fiddler and
Fiddler acts a little bit like a man in
the middle and it can make changes to
files as they're loaded so I'm going to
go and jump into an event theyve got
different events here on before request
on before response I'm going to jump
into on before response and down here
I've got a very special Trump ification
script now here's what's going to happen
when I run this so when I reload the
script file and it comes through Fiddler
it's going to modify it as it comes
through and and what we're really trying
to emulate here is what would happen if
that Javascript file from cloud flare
was modified before it got to the
browser now in the case of the Trump
situation in the GitHub site we'd sort
of be more worried about it being
modified in in storage but this is just
going to let us sort of emulate what
would happen so here's what we'll do
let's just go and open up this one here
open that go up there so this is the
script as it stands this is what was
loaded into the browser and I just jump
down to the bottom and there's you know
nothing too special there if I give that
a hard refresh so that will now pull it
through Fiddler and it should get
modified if I jump down to the bottom
okay now we've got Trump ification
script so let's now reload the site and
again what we're sort of trying to
emulate here is what would happen if
this script was changed somewhere else
so hard refresh it's going to pull it
through Fiddler it's going to add the
Trump ification script we're going to
see how this website changes in a
potentially malicious way so Trump is
thinking apparently he apparently
doesn't do a lot of that but here we are
all right so we've now got like little
driving Trump all over the place because
what the script is done is it's actually
modified the Dom and well the script
itself has modified the Dom and it's
injected background image into every div
so what we've demonstrated is that we've
changed the file outside of the site the
site is now getting something different
to what it expected it's still running
you can do
this still works still works okay so
that's the problem that we're trying to
solve let's go and have a look at
another
site who's used this one
before oh wow that's a lot who's been in
uh the Dropbox data
Bridge LinkedIn data
Bridge Ashley Madison data
Bridge come on that is the correct
answer by the way Ashley what I don't
know all right just do the same thing
going to view the source jump down to
the end I am also embedding a library
from cloud flare down here so I'm
exposing myself to the same problem so
let's do the same thing I'll pop that
open another tab jump down the end
there's no Trump ification script in
there because this is the case version
from
before but if I give it a hard reload
and we ignore those Fiddler errors like
so that'll pull it from cloud flare
through Fiddler and then I go down the
end and now we've got Trump
ification So in theory we should see my
precious website with Trump all over it
in theory let's have a look so we'll go
back to here we'll give it another hard
reload now as it's reloading going to
hit F12 into the dev tools we going to
leave the console
open and we get an error now this is an
error that wasn't there before and I'm
going to zoom this in a little bit so
you can see what's going on it says
failed to find a valid digest in the
Integrity attribute for the resource and
then it goes on and it gives us this
sort of CDM path with computed sh 256
integrity and we got this great big hash
here and what we're actually seeing here
is something called SRI or subresource
integrity and the way it works is that
if I go back and look at my source code
here you'll see that whilst this begins
like a normal script tag it then says
let's add an attribute called integrity
and we've actually got a sh 384 hash
here which goes all the way through to
there now here's the the beauty of how
this works you get yourself a Javascript
file or you can do it with CSS as well
but in this case it's JavaScript you get
yourself a Javascript file that you
trust okay so in this okaye it was J cre
so I trust J cre 2.2.4 I trust this file
I create a hash of that file and I add
it to the Integrity
attribute I can now go and grab that
file from wherever I like public cdns
GitHub something that someone else
controls and when the file downloads and
it sees that there's an Integrity
attribute on the script tag it hashes
the file and it checks it and if they
don't match we get this
error now the really neat thing here as
well is that my site still works even
though it has blocked the file and it
still works because I got a fallback
position just here and it looks to see
if it can find window. jQuery it won't
be able to because the browser has
rejected the file and not run it and if
it can't find it it says okay well look
let's do this let's actually write out a
reference to my own local J crew file
it's so magic right and if you want to
make one of these you can grab a copy of
whatever Library it is wanting to embed
and then you can go over to S has
generator paste it in and say hash it
and it'll go away retrieve the file you
got to make sure that that one is good
and there are other ways of generating
the hash as well and then it will go
okay here's your
tag so this is awesome because this
allows you to have your cake and eat it
too right so what's not to
love browser support all right let's do
browser
support there is one one issue
here one uh particular manufacturer's
browser you know I'm G don't
you so uh no support in IE and no
support in Edge which is which is kind
of a bit of a shame because we'd really
like to be able to use this more and
what it means is that if I go and grab
say Internet Explorer like so and I go
to have I been pawned now that's from
case right but if I give this hard
reload the same thing's going to happen
right it's going to pull that file
through Fiddler Fiddler's going to add
the Trump ification script and my
beautiful website is going to have
somewhat of a problem so you've got to
sort of make a decision there he goes
he's all over the place so this didn't
happen in
Chrome this actually also won't happen
in Firefox there's just again one sort
of skew of browsers so you got to make a
decision like do you go and embed things
from external resources and get all the
benefits of
CDN but then take the risk with
non-supporting
browsers or do you just load everything
locally and then you don't get the
upsides so swings and roundabouts here
so here's what I'm going to do I'm going
to just close that one down because I
really don't want to keep seeing uh
everything Trump ified I don't think
that's going to make for a good
demo all right so that's SRI let's go
into something different and I thought
I'd talk about scams for a while because
you see a lot of scams that run on the
internet and recently I saw this one
Twitter
verification and this site was offering
to help you get verified so you go along
here and you you click on the get
started button you go and enter all your
credit card
details I'm sure that'll work out just
fine uh except it probably won't work
out just fine this was linked to from a
promoted tweet which is kind of ironic
as
well this is at payment. HTM
you strip payment. HTML
out and you have a problem you have no
default document you have a directory
listing you look around a little bit and
you go oh here's an interesting
file and this is what we often see right
so we often see these scam fishing
websites stood up with the local index
of everyone who signed up and it's just
sitting there like just dumped out to a
text file and look at all the data here
it's including things like cvvs from
credit cards all personal
info I went and registered on one of
these just for fun just to see what
would happen and it did that uh so they
may also not be outputting coding which
is which is also a bit of a
problem we see a lot of scams around
right like we see a lot of scams
happening on the web and I saw one a
little while ago uh which was
this and I don't know if this happens in
Norway or the other places that you're
all from but one of the things that
happens in Australia a lot is you'll be
at home and it's like 6:00 at night
you're cooking the dinner and trying to
organize the
kids and someone calls up and there's
that sort of long wait when you pick up
the phone like a a Vie call from a long
way
away and then an Indian voice comes on
the line and says where from Microsoft
you've got viruses does that happen here
all right well this is the lady doing it
believe it or not this is kantra and
kantra is the site which has perpetuated
a lot of these scams
now this kept happening to me as well
and it was driving me nuts because I was
like look I know it's it's a scam you
know go away I'm not going to talk to
you I don't think the crm's very good
cuz they kept calling me and eventually
I went all right if you want to keep
calling me I would like to see where
you're going to go with this so I
created a very special VM which is this
one just
here now I thought okay what I'll do is
I'll create my special VM and I'll put
some interesting things on the desktop
so you'll see I've got stuff like I
pretended I was Max so I've got Max's
Porn Stash up there I've got passwords
finances I thought the whole Bond and
Rick Ashley thing might give it away uh
turns out scam is not so smart so here's
how the scam works right they call you
up and they go you know we're from
Microsoft etc etc imagine let's say
non-technical people so think about
elderly relatives are often the sort of
people that get hit so the scam is
talking to them and they go okay you've
got viruses and they're like oh no can
you help fix it and they're like yeah
sure we can help you what you do is you
go to your PC press Windows R type in e
v NT
vwr which many of you all know will take
us to the Event Viewer and when you're
in the Event Viewer then they say okay
open up the windows logs go down to
application and when you're there just
start scrolling through and if you see
any errors oh holy [__] they're
viruses and of course the the the person
on the other end of the line is like
well it's red it doesn't look very good
does it you know maybe I do have viruses
and they then go through the social
engineering process of getting you to
give them remote control to your desktop
they install crapware and all sorts of
other things you don't need all of this
is for free and then they tell you you
got to pay them and if you don't pay
them in some cases they just nuke the
entire
machine so these are the guys
right they're over here
now as it turns out they were working
this morning when I prepared this
demo now they're ret turning 500 which
isn't so good but it doesn't matter
because what I wanted to show you is
still there if I go to Ford robots.txt
just like all the database
backups are sitting there but don't
worry it's in a robots file you're not
actually allowed to go there
so scam scammers they they do like to
scam and it's it's just interesting when
we look at the ways that data is exposed
and you know inevitably at stuff like
this now there's all their customers
sitting
there often we see websites breached and
we see all sorts of reasons about look
there must have been like really
malicious people going in there breaking
into it and I kind of like hanlin's
razor and Helen's Razer basically says
look when you see something like this
it's not necessarily that someone was
malicious it may just be that someone
else was
stupid and here's what we we're going to
look at now because we're going to look
at sort of places where data is exposed
so readily uh ultimately through
mistakes so there's a really good
example here this is an Indian Pathology
lab and an Indian Pathology Lab that got
breached breached back in uh back in
last year around about December time
frame and there was a bit of a problem
where 43,000 pathology reports were
retained by other people now pathology
reports is things like what's the
results of your blood test what's the
results of uh say in utro test when a
woman's pregnant what's the result of
your HIV test 43,000 records publicly
exposed and they put out a
statement this actually came via the
Press their website was
hacked they were filing a complaint with
the cybercell of Mumbai police which
sounds really
scary now you want to know how they're
hacked I'll show you somebody went
here all right so it it's just a full-on
directory
listing and here's the amazing thing we
we sort of see this stuff all the time
where there's huge amounts of data that
get inadvertently exposed publicly on
websites and the the sort of disturbing
thing with this particular case is I was
trying to get in touch with them I
couldn't get in touch with them someone
had sent me this link it certainly
wasn't me going around looking for
pathology reports incidentally the
reason we knew that there were things
like HIV tests is because all of this
got indexed by Google 43,000 Documents
so you could do a Google and search for
the scope that was limited to this site
and then just add like HIV to the end
and you got to see Google cases of the
entire documents without ever actually
accessing and loading them from the
site so I'm in touch with them and I'm
going look you know I think you probably
should lock these up couldn't get
through a journalist eventually gets
through and these guys tell the
journalist this is in December was about
the first of December they said
uh we're actually fixing this we're
launching a new website next month and
it will be good then and this is what
they said like we're just going to leave
all this out there for a month and then
fix it and then they got a lot of social
pressure and that sort of it expedited
things shall we
say now you might look at this and go
okay well this is like just a little
Indian pathology
website why don't we go look at
something a little bit bigger and this
was around the same time frame This was
later last year and this was actually
related to Michael
page now Michael page is a really large
Global recruitment company they're all
over the world and someone got in touch
with me and they said uh I've got
Michael page data and people just
context it's not like they get in touch
with me because of my Australian
Heritage and they know I've got the
criminal thing going they they get they
get in touch with me because they think
well maybe this will be useful data for
have I been pawned right I can put it in
there I can make it searchable so a guy
gets in touch with me he says I got this
data and then he says Michael page is
Cap
Gemini it's like well no it's not what
do you mean and he said well what's
actually happened here is Cap Gemini and
in case you don't know who Cap Gemini
are they're one of the world's largest
Outsourcing providers they got revenue
of about 11 billion EUR a year they hire
180,000 people worldwide I mean they are
massive and anyway it turned out that
there was a bit of an issue on capgemini
side and what I thought I'd do first is
show you the way this was represented
the way it was written up and then we'll
look at what the issue was so the write
up
said there was an unauthorized third
party who are lead legally gained
access and that second line sort of
sounds like someone did something pretty
nasty
right here's what they
did they opened a
website now what was actually happening
the guy that found this what he was
doing is he was just scanning the ipv4
address range looking for directory
listings so just going through knocking
on Port 80 just going hey uh let's just
make a get request do you return a pay
that has index of in the title and do
you have AQL gzip yes okay great found
something and he gets hits over and over
and over and over again because
organizations do this and what I think
is really interesting with the Cap
Gemini example as opposed to say the
India example is that a lot of times
people say well you know the Indian one
it's a small company they don't have
many people maybe not a lot of
expertise but this is very much the
opposite of this right this is a total
end of the
scale and what we know from this is that
it doesn't really matter how large the
organization is and we don't just know
that from this we know it from a lot of
other empirical evidence no matter how
big they are they tend to get exposed to
the same
risks let me give you an example of what
I mean by this does anyone know what a
Google do
is now this is not my Australian accent
saying Google doc this is do as in like
the derogatory term but I'll show you
what I mean we can go over to a browser
and we'll just grab this one here and we
can give it a bit of something like uh
we were just seeing on the screen index
of so I'll search for index of I got a
saved one here uh let's actually go back
because that is not exactly what I
wanted to try that again index of dose.
gzip so I'll zoom in and show you what
we've done
here that's easy
yeah yeah and then we've got all of
these results of websites with database
backups just sitting there like that
takes seconds and here are thousands and
thousands of websites and you could
click through to any of these and see
the
data now that would be hacking so we
won't do that but it's not hacking if
you just look at Google
Cas so so far I haven't been proven
wrong so
far we're recording this aren't we oh
[__] all right it'll be fine I'll be
back in
Australia
so long as this goes live after I get
back all right but you see the point and
I guess the kind of crazy thing about it
is there's stuff like this just all over
the web and even if it's not like
database backups what if we went back
one and we just gave it a bit of uh a
bit of dogit do you think anyone would
publish the git repositories
publicly of course they would why
not now fortunately nobody ever puts
anything sensitive in a git repository
so this really doesn't
matter but you can imagine how happens
right like someone's just picked up the
entire directory of the website and gone
hey let's just grab this and we'll just
dump it on the production site you know
pick it all up and publish it we've
probably all done this at one stage in
the
past so there's a huge amount of data
that's just sitting out there massively
publicly
facing now moving on one of the other
things that tends to happen a lot is we
get very sensitive about personal
attributes of data being exposed so
particularly in Europe you're very very
privacy conscious so we've got things
like our names addresses our phone
numbers we or you guys citizens and
residents of of Europe own that data
it's personal data and I want to talk a
little bit about how that gets exposed
now I'll uh I'll skip past yet another
trumpism uh if you like seeing more
things about Trump come to pubcon
tomorrow night that'll be a different
thing and we'll uh we'll just sort of
get a little bit of little bit of
insight about the sorts of personal dat
attributes that people like to have
access to hey I got two of these phone
books didn't know if you wanted one hey
how long have we known each other long
time and yet we've never discussed
mother's maiden names the names of old
pets high school mascots favorite
teachers heck I don't even know the last
four digits of your
Social all useful info right like it's
all useful info that people such as
social Engineers Fishers identity
thieves want to have so it's info that
we need to protect very very
carefully which brings me to these
guys there may be some people in the
audience who've seen me right about this
before for everyone else get ready for
this strawberry net is a Hong Kong based
Cosmetics website and what they do is
they sell a whole bunch of things online
Cosmetics as it were and you can go to
Strawberry net and you can buy many of
these things so I might be looking
through here and saying well oil-free
moisturizer I'm not sure why I need
oilfree moisturizer but it looks good
let's take one of those now we're going
to add it to the bag and go and check
out and we're going to Express checkout
and this is where it starts to get
interesting what you do because this is
a cosmetic site and it's probably going
to be used by more women than men you
pick a female name you pick a common
one let's say Sarah Sarah is pretty
common and then you go okay let's pick a
common domain name a common email
provider like
Gmail and let's now go and try this
Express checkout and we'll see how this
goes see if there's anything
interesting in the way this is
done now in case you are looking at this
and going well Troy this is very
irresponsible you should be reporting
this privately sit tight because you're
going to see how try how hard I have
tried and how they actually view
this now you might also be looking at
this and going well like it's bad
because there's personal info on there
but they've obfuscated it which is good
but then they do this change billing
address now I'm going to zoom in a
little bit because I want you to be to
experience this in it's full
Glory watch very very
carefully ah
now luckily all of that disappeared
before any of you could see it
properly so that's
okay except it's not really okay because
you can go over and you can use your
inspector and inspect that field and
find out that it does actually have a
name in it and you might then be looking
at this and saying well for a girl named
Sarah dick is a really unusual first
name and you might then be looking at
the other field next to it the last name
field and go it's also quite odd that
her last name is
but because the problem is is that this
is change billing address and you can go
in and change it to anything else you
like without any authorization it's just
I know an email
address and it's this when I saw this it
was just unfathomable so I was running a
workshop for a government Department
actually in Australia and we do this
enumeration module where we say look
what are the ways where data might be
exposed from a website H so for example
you put an email address into the
password reset feature and it comes back
and says it is there and we sent you an
email or it's not there that's leakage
right because it tells you the email
address is on the
site so when I was told about this I was
like you got to tell them you got to let
them know and the guys like no really I
tried and they came back to me and they
said don't worry because we've got SSL
on the
site so
so
basically as some sort of freaky stalker
pervert is siphoning women's data out of
the site anyone else trying to hack them
on the wire can't see the
data so I wrote about this and a bunch
of people got very angry and they wrote
to Strawberry net and said look this is
ridiculous and strawberry net very
kindly replied and they had some reasons
they said well look we are actually PCI
Compliant all of this is on my blog too
I'm am not making this up go and have a
look at it and uh someone else wrote to
them they came back and said yeah well
customers like our system with no
password now I don't know who exactly
they surveyed maybe like the internal
marketing team I don't
know and my favorite one where they said
using your email address as your
password is sufficient
security this is why I know I have a
long and prosperous career in this
industry it's stuff like
this all right let's go on and do
something a little bit different and I
thought we'd talk a little bit about SQL
injection because SQL injection is still
a massive topic on the internet and
you're going to see what I mean by this
shortly so we'll start with a little
video
now I admit I have corrupted a lot of
databases with
SQL usually my
own but how do we know they're
hacking green screen very good all right
this is out of the Jason Bourne movie
and I just thought it was funny the way
they represent it but inevitably they're
talking about SQL injection and I want
to sort of start to go through a few of
the mechanics of how SQL injection works
and I'm going to do a few demos and show
you a few things and the way I like to
demo this is there's a blog post here
and it's a blog post that someone wrote
A couple of years ago and I normally
wouldn't be up here in front of a
crowd basically pulling it apart which
is what we're going to do but as you'll
see a little bit later this guy wrote
the blog post it's got some uh let's
just say creative things in it and I
left a very very nice polite comment
saying you really probably don't want to
do this and what about this and the
other injection things and he ignored it
and then all these people came in
afterwards and said thank you this is
very useful I've just done this on my
site and I go ah well I sort of go oh
[__] not more of it and then I go I'm
going to have such a good career in this
industry but look let's just start
having a look at it and I'm going to
scroll down a little bit and we'll uh
we'll stop somewhere and just just sort
of ask the audience what we do and don't
like so let's start with the connection
string how do we feel about this
connection
string now it's dark but somehow I can
still see a lot of shaking heads what
don't we like about
it okay so so uh look if you said
password that is an eight character
password they're all sequential numbers
probably not so good some people may
have said well this is not the way that
we should be creating a connection
string into a database in asp.net
other people may have said well you
probably also shouldn't really be using
sa like sa is is not a particularly
great way of connecting into the
database because a very highly
privileged account it's it's basically
God wres you can do
anything do you think that happens
though does it happen
much you want to know how to find out
all right I'll show you of course you do
okay so let's uh in fact we'll go back
to there we'll grab a new tab and we'll
do another Google doc and we can do a
Google doc for
inurl web
config now let's have a look at what's
Happening
Here
FTP because Google indexes things over
FTP if you leave it anonymously
accessible web.config anyone doing
asp.net knows what that is anyone who's
not doing it this is where your
connection strings are and your API keys
and the things that you want to keep
secret and web servers such as I are
designed to never return this but you
can on FTP because that's how some
people get the files there and we've got
hundreds of results of web doc configs
being returned and as we established you
could go and click through to any of
these but like we said earlier that
would be hacking but there are CED
versions
and it looks empty because it's XML and
it doesn't render to the screen but when
you view the source code you can see
it so we've got those there but getting
back to the point of
sa let's just filter this down a little
bit I'm going to take that out and we'll
just put a we'll just put an SAA in here
because we would expect to see that in a
connection string in the exposed
web.config
and what do you know we find
them
saay uh not such a good password that
one
also not so
good uh probably even
worse and we we kind of see this over
and over and over again and there's sort
of an an interesting I guess issue with
this when we go back to here which is
that often when I see code on a blog
post that is it may be sort of ancillary
to the purpose of the post itself so for
example this post is about how to do a
password reset and I'll hear people say
no look don't worry about this because
this this is not what I'm writing about
it's just like an illustration you know
look at the bit doing the
reset and I'll sort of say to people
yeah but you know that people will come
along and they'll copy and paste this
and they will use exactly what is in
this code published somewhere on the web
on their own site without understanding
it let me show you how I know
this I wrote about something a while ago
about the niss and leaf now this was
earlier last year and for those of you
who don't know what a niss leaf is
you're probably not from Norway cuz
they're everywhere here they're these
little
cars and someone in my workshop when I
was here in Oslo in January last
year we do this exercise where you get
your phone and you proxy your phone
through your PC and you look at the
traffic that your phone sends to the
PC and the guy in my workshop had an n
and leaf and he's like I wonder how my
phone knows which Leaf to speak to like
how does it know to say turn the heating
on in my leaf instead of the heating in
someone else's now being from Australia
I didn't even know this was a thing
right we have a whole set of different
problems it's like you get in your car
when it's hot and the sun's out and the
seat belt buckle is there and you get
branded serious it's the real thing so
we're not used to turning the heater on
our car but apparently here you are and
uh he wanted to figure it out and
eventually he found what the API key was
in his phone that identified his car the
secret that would allow him to control
the temperature in his car pull back the
battery status find the trip history and
what he learned is that secret is the
VIN number and in case you don't know
what a VIN number it is an API key
printed in every cars
windscreen and I was here in Norway just
walking around past cars going there's
an API key there's I was just taking
photos the thing is though you didn't
even need to know someone else's API key
because they're innumerable and it's
basically just the last five or six
digits where you can just randomize them
and every now and then you get a hit you
get another
car so we reported this to niss and said
uh you probably should fix your cars and
that to be honest it it wasn't an easy
exercise a month later they still hadn't
fixed it it was still exposed this was
Private disclosure responsible
disclosure and after a month I said okay
look I have seen enough evidence that
there is R from this a privacy risk with
people pulling back data are risks in
terms of I think most niss and leaf
owners would not actually want someone
else controlling a physical part of
their car which is what the climate
control is so I published a blog post
and that's the blog post you see here
and then they pulled the service
straight away it just
disappeared and it went offline for
quite some time and eventually it came
back online and they had a new app and
this is the
app now does does anyone see anything in
this app at all
unusual in case you're not seeing it
read from the bottom
up this is the real app this is what
they put out there in the App
Store and I I want to explain how this
happened and and the way I'm going to do
it is I'm just going to I'm just going
to flick over here I'm going to go to uh
going to go to here uh you know this
site don't you um going to of here I'm
going to go down to
there so someone copied and pasted code
out of stack Overflow and put it in an
app that controls cars without reading
it and pushed it out to the
world but it's even worse because what
do the first two words here
say the spirit
yeah what do the first two words here
say some someone actually read that and
typed it
out which makes it even worse because
they had all of these keystrokes where
they mind could have gone maybe this
isn't such a good
idea but they did it anyway because it
seemed like a good idea at the time I
assume okay so look let's get back to
this bloke for a second uh if we go back
to our SQL injection
site how do we feel about this sequel
here is this good sequel in terms of
injection or Bad sequel show our hands
who thinks it's
bad who thinks it's
good oh you know what for those of you
down the front there are a lot more
people thinking it was bad than good
this is actually good and the reason
it's good is that when we look at where
we've got email just
here this is parameterization and we've
got email decorated with a little at
symbol and then we go to the select
command go to the parameters collection
and we add Emil which matches up to that
guy and then we get the T the text value
from this txt email
field now what parameterization means is
that no matter what value gets put in
that field it will not change the
structure of the query it will always
try and find an email address that has
that exact value so this is good
parameterization is what we want to do
to protect against seq injection
risks how do we feel about the next one
who thinks it's
good who thinks it's bad the bads have
it okay so the problem we've got here
and the reason I show this is it's just
beautiful to put them both right next to
each other the good and the bad in the
bad what we're doing is we're taking
that txt email field and we're just
concatenating it into a great big string
and then no matter what you put in that
field it will form part of the query and
when it goes down and executes non-query
the D database doesn't know what is
query and what is data it just has this
one big
statement so if for example I was to
create an email address
called single quote semic colum drop
table login table D
Dash and send it to there this would
execute it would drop the login table
and I know it would drop the login table
because the guy's connecting with sa and
I can do whatever the hell I
want so this is a beautiful example and
and to my earlier Point as we scroll
down a little bit uh I left him a very
nice comment I thought friendly
feedback and what sort of struck me as
alarming is okay this is kind of
alarming I'm not sure why but
anyway as we went down you get people
saying uh you know really
helpful
useful thank you very nice and easy to
understand and you realize that a lot of
the bad stuff you see on the internet
is just replicated from other
places I think at some point probably
around about this stage this was
September last year I think I tweeted
this because the the tone started to
change and I was sort of like are you
sure easy copy
paste reset passwords at the bank I and
it's right about here I go I think the
trolls are into this right and and as it
goes on they start to go no security
flaws at all we were hacked within the
first
week and and this one Google when you
get home don't do it here trust
me okay so this is how we see SQL
injection risks sort of propagating in
this way now the other sort of side to
the risk is that we see really
bad I guess really bad advice about how
to go and hack this stuff and and
probably the best way to illustrate this
is I'm going to show you a video that I
found on YouTube where someone talks
about how to go and break into sites
exactly like the one we just saw now
bear with me I'm going to show you a few
little clips from this guys and or this
guy and I'll uh I'll give a few comments
on it as well let's do a professional
video Let's actually show you how the
concept works and um I'm using um uh the
SQL or skill method here skill
injection now did anyone else hear that
and not think of this
right except it's a hacking
scrw now the guy sounds you know like
maybe 15 16 he's a kid and and this is
sort of part of the observation here
which is that SQL injection is such a
severe flaw but it's also such an easily
exploitable one that we see children
getting into it so this guy goes on
let's listen to a little bit more but I
I will teach you how to do that and and
there are easy methods to do this so do
not worry do not worry about this um
yeah um I just uh don't worry about the
little jump cut
there okay so uh maybe not like plural
site standards of
[Laughter]
training all right so then he goes on
and he goes to this website and this is
a website that's got a whole bunch of
various hacks on it and he's looking at
what you now know as a Google doc and
he's going to show you how he used this
Google do to break into a
website um sorry oh I don't know I
forgot that five Fox do that so the
first site was this one which is
literally this so if I just go on here
yeah this opens up
this okay so first of all see how
indiscriminate this was like he's just
gone let's search Google the first
result we get is the one we're going to
hack into this is not targeted it's not
like like these people have wronged me
you know they're killing babies or
genetically modifying food or whatever
other [__] reason activists come up
with his criteria was you're at the top
of
Google okay so with this extension what
we do is put a little apostrophe here
little
Commish put it there press enter and
there we go so this means that we have
an error in the database so there's an
error in their database so and their
database is
MySQL server there you go so because
it's my um school or MySQL we can Target
it and grab all the
info it's easy isn't it and the scary
thing is he's right because if you jump
over to a browser and you do another
Google doc for something like in url uh
let's say PHP because we know that's
going to have
issues this is a net Centric event isn't
it just making sure and we you sort of
just grab random stuff and you go okay
this one's got an ID in it this one's
got an ID in it uh this one down here's
got an ID in it and we go over there and
we say let's just put one character in
because one character is not hacking I
don't
think uh okay that's got a sequel
exception there let's put one character
in here uh that's got a squel exception
there let's put one character in here uh
that's got a SLE exception
there now this th honestly this was me
just doing this this was not
pre-recorded video you can try this at
home don't go any further than that all
right so let's see what happens next so
next you want to um have this program
hav all right so this sort of takes us
to the point in because what he's going
to do now is he uses this freely
available software to break in and the
the amazing thing about this again is
that he's a kid right he's a kid
managing to break in and pull data out
of the system so I thought we'll do
another Dem we'll make this a real
really interesting interactive demo and
I'll get like the the youngest person I
can find to break into this all right
what about you you're you're little come
up here you want to have a go all
right okay so what's your name Ari Ari
how old are you Ari seven right and
we've never met before have we yes we
have
Dad all
right
so why don't you get up here you you
need a stool cuz you're only a little
hacker now here's what we're going to do
I'm just going to don't hack other sites
all right we we got to hack just the
right site so we're going to go to let's
go to here all right so now AR's going
to do a demo so Ari let's let's have a
look at what happens here this is a site
of mine that you're allowed to hack now
he's going down here and he's selecting
one of the cars here one of the
manufacturers he's found McLaren's and
he's copying the URL now if you know how
to copy you can be a hacker too so he's
copying this he's going to put it on the
clipboard now once he has this he's
halfway there because he can then go
down and open free hacking software this
is what we just saw right haage and he's
pasting this into a field that says
Target now once he's got that in there
he goes and analyzes and this is just
making HTTP requests so hitting the
website website goes down to the
database and it's pulling data back out
of the database it's trying to figure
out what the database name is and it
comes back up and it says here's your
database name DB he he's moving ahead of
me okay so then he goes and he gets
tables cuz he's getting all the tables
out of the database and he goes okay I
got those those are good he has to
choose which table he wants he goes a
user profile that looks pretty good
doesn't it why don't I get all the
columns out of the user profile data and
user profile table here's all the
columns so now he's just got to figure
out what he actually wants from there
he's smart so he's going to email
address and of course he's going to
password as well and then the only thing
he's got to do is get data and then here
comes all the data out of the
system give Ari Round of Applause that's
awesome
now we we practiced this and there was
something you forgot before you started
hacking uh
what ah there we go now he's hacking all
right
good
boy okay so on that note let's finish
there but we got a little bit of time in
case you want to ask are any questions
about sequel or myself as well does
anyone have any questions about what we
just
saw or is it just like stunned
silence would you go home and teach your
children I don't do
that yes over
here sorry
again why are all those sites still
online it's a bit of a mystery
actually um they may still be online but
there may be lots of backups of their
database in uh in other places but it's
it's amazing a lot of them get taken
down but a lot of them pop up again very
soon as well and I wonder how much
people realize their data is actually
being exfiltrated from the system
because if it's like seal injection and
it's it's non-damaging they're literally
just selecting data out all right and a
lot of them don't even know very often
when I get sent data breaches the first
the organization knows is when I go uh
is this your data and they're like
actually it is our data we didn't know
had no
idea any other
questions
yes all right so when I find a security
breach how long do I wait before uh
doing
what before publishing it okay so this
the short answer is it depends now
something like niss is a good example
and and this adheres to what I think
most Security Professionals would say is
sort of disclosure best practice I got
in touch with them privately they
responded quickly we emailed back and
forwards we spoke that week and then
nothing happened and I kept emailing
them and saying what's the status are
you fixing this people are at risk and
what eventually happened is we got to
the point where I knew that other people
were exploiting this and that's when I
said okay guys look I'm going to publish
this tomorrow are there any comments or
anything that you would like to add to
the blog post so that was one month and
I had to make a call based on the
exposure the risk to people and then the
risk of if I did disclose what would
happen like would people start to
exploit it before they could shut it
down there are other cases where there
are things that I would never publicly
share like the the um the Pathology Lab
data even if they hadn't fixed it a
month later I'm not going to write a
blog post going here are 43,000 reports
that include HIV results so it's
definitely Case by case and it really
depends on the company doing the right
thing and responding responsibly as
well
yes okay so he said is the Integrity
check just a method for validating
scripts such as the Trump ification
script
uh so that is the only method we have
that is native in the browser that
allows you to check the Integrity of an
external file and like I said like that
works on JavaScript it also works on CSS
as well so long as you're using Chrome
or Firefox that's that's the
caveats anyone
else
yeah
all
right so the the question here is that
do I have any any tips to help websites
respond faster when you you do report
something because you've reported
something and they're not fixing it in a
speedy fashion right uh honestly the tip
is is that I get to a point where I go
okay well look this is going to be
public and it's going to be public
either via my blog or the other one that
I find is really useful is journalists
are very very good at getting traction
and that there's a few useful things
about going to a journalist so one is
that when a company hears it's a
journalist contacting them asking about
a security breach and they're going to
write something they're like okay so
this is actually going to be in the
newspaper it's going to be serious the
other is is that it does divest a little
bit of risk from me because I'm not the
one having to have that direct
discussion where they might get
threatening or legal or things like that
and finally journalists and there are
some really good security journalists
out there so people like Joseph Cox from
motherboard or Zack Whitaker from ZDNet
they're very used to framing security
issues with companies they're security
journalists so getting in touch with
someone like that if you found something
really interesting also helps expedite
things I got time for about one more any
others
yes good question so many attack vectors
how can I as a developer no I'm not
screwing up have a think about the
things you saw today most of you are
pretty sure when you're doing that right
like I left my databases publicly
exposed not so good I would say that the
single most thing and I have a vested
interest given what I do uh is training
for developers so I've been doing
training here this week we did a a
two-day workshop on Monday and Tuesday
I'll be back here in January doing
another Workshop as well actually for
the same organizers this event and just
spending a couple of days sort of going
through the way these risks work and the
way attacks occur makes a fundamental
difference and it's just two days and
you take that and you use that for
dozens of projects over many many years
so that's that's my answer I honestly
think uh definitely the best possible
thing you can do is develop a
training we're out of time so thank you
very much for for coming everyone I hope
you enjoyed Ari and my
talk